merci d'applaudir clair qu'à telle
monnaie
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir je souhaite vous faire partager
ce soir le bonheur d'être solidaires
tout au long d'une histoire qui commence
en 2004 alors trois maires trois filles
trois touareg
nous traversons le ténéré le plus grand
désert du sahara pour aller vivre une
semaine dans un village touareg au nord
d'univers en plein désert alors pourquoi
cette histoire est bien parce que mon
amie madeleine avait envie d'aller vivre
une expérience de deux mois une
expérience de méditation dans ce village
qu'elle avait rencontre qu'elle avait
découvert quelques années avant lors
d'une randonnée chamelière et puis moi
moi j'aime le désert je rêve d' aventure
africaine jus du boche pourrait
peut-être de tuer accompagner un petit
moment et puis je propose à mon amie
marie qui me dit oui pas de problème
mais pas sans ma fille
alors du coup on est parties chacune
avec sa fille donc on arrive on arrive
dans ce village on est accueilli dans la
maison d'étrangers avec son porte sans
fenêtre sans toi et avec de l'eau et des
nattes et la première nuit je suis quand
même assez impressionnante et je
n'entendais les chacals les chiens je me
disais qu'ils vont tous venir nous
dévorer dans cette maison à trous et et
je disais à marie c'est quand même un
peu limite d'avoir emmené nos filles ici
la mène avec une devant et dans ce monde
qui à l'heure comme assez hostile et
elle me dit même limite dépassée et on
n'a pas dormi de la nuit et on s'est dit
mais maintenant on est là faut assumer
notre choix qu'un peu foot certes mais
donc la première chose qu'on a fait le
lendemain matin on a dit s'il vous plaît
une porte alors on a aussi découvert
pendant cette semaine la vie de ce
village est donc un a pris un nouveau
quotidien sans confort où tout est
compliqué où tout prend du temps et où
le moindre bobo
vous fait frôler un peu la mort quand on
est rentré de ce voyage initiatique
on était plus les mêmes et moi je me
suis dit j'ai quelque chose à faire dans
ce coin du monde perdue extrêmement
pauvre et je décide d'y retourner en
tant que médecin je propose à mes deux
amis qui sont d'accord pour
m'accompagner marietton médecin
c'était très pratique en 2005 nous voilà
partis et on va de petits centres de
santé en petit centre de santé proposer
nos services aux agents sanitaires qui
sont souvent très livrés à eux mêmes qui
n'ont pas de moyens peu de formation et
qui généralement sont très contentes de
voir arriver
donc on consulte avec eux et on essaye
de faire un petit peu de formation sinon
on fait aussi des réunions de femmes
pour faire un peu de prévention et aussi
pour qu'elle puisse poser des questions
et donc c'est comme ça qu'on a appris
que sur une brûlure et bien les femmes
touareg dans le désert elle met du caca
de lapin ou du dentifrice
c'est vrai qu'on avait beaucoup appris
ce jour là mais après je me suis dit bah
oui il n'y a pas d'eau où elle est très
loin des fois il faut faire des
kilomètres pour aller chercher l'eau on
a quand même essayé avec marie de leur
expliquer que c'était quand même bien de
trouver un petit peu d'eau et de laisser
le pied du bébé brûlé dans la bassine
alors mari faisait le bébé moi je
faisais la maman et ont laissé le bébé
pleurer pour leur montrer que des fois
c'est comme ça fait partie du traitement
et les mamans rigolait bien et on a donc
de très très bons souvenirs de ces
échanges
on a aussi travaillé dans les campements
de naumann loin des villages et là on a
pu apprendre la vie des nomades et puis
le dernier jour de notre de notre
premier périple on s'arrête dans un fils
dans un petit village et je vais voir
l'agent sanitaire et jeux ludiques août
on a vraiment eu beaucoup le temps mais
si tu as un patient à nous montrer c'est
maintenant quoi et puis la leaf hergnies
du non non non je personnes et puis on
retourne à la voiture et je tombe sur un
enfant complètement prostré avec une
énorme brûlures sur la jambe
il avait dit qu'il avait personne à
montrer moi je suis dermato et bon ben
pas de problème vite on va tous chercher
les pansements ont fait les soins on
explique comment il faut les faire et ce
petit garçon s'appelle mano il était il
n'a pas dit
un mot tellement il était courageux en
france il aurait été sous anesthésie
générale dans le service des grands
brûlés et quand j'ai compris que cet
enfant était quand même un peu livré à
lui-même depuis le mois qu'il attendait
avec sa jambe brûlé je me suis dit j'ai
pas confiance au père qui s'en occupe
pas j'ai compris le chef du village et
je lui dis je te confie cet enfant avec
l'agent sanitaire et je vous préviens je
reviendrai je t'ai pas du tout sûr de
revenir mais on est rentré en france et
moi j'avais vraiment mano dans le coeur
et tous les jours j'ai pensé à man où je
me suis dit faut que gère-t-on donc en
2006 eh ben on a fait rebelote on est
retourné les mêmes et on a été re voir
les mêmes agences amical et même
infirmées et c'était vraiment très
plaisant de les retrouver
et puis on voulait savoir si ce qu'on
avait fait ça avait servi un petit peu à
quelque chose et le dernier jour le
grand jour il faut retrouver mano donc
on va dans le village de mano pas de
mano alors là je dis aux guides je te
préviens tu me trouves mano moi je
rentre pas en france si j'ai pas vu mano
alors bon il s'est dit je le trouve donc
on est parti à travers piste est au bout
de trois quatre heures on est enfin
arrivé dans l'oued de la maman de mano
et mano était là-bas pour pour
jardiniers pour aider sa maman et il est
arrivé en courant vers nous et là j'ai
donc compris qu'il était guéri je sais
tu es tellement émue et les trois mamans
on était très ému
moi je pleurais comme une madeleine et
je rencontre sa maman qui me fait le
plus beau cadeau qui me dit tu es sa
deuxième maman
alors ouais là mon petit mano et quand
on a pu vivre ces belles retrouvailles
est bon on est reparti en france et est
donc ça c'est 2006 et on a décidé de
créer l'association 1 s'ouvre pour un
sourire alors ce nom c'est moi qui l'ait
choisie pour moi ça a du sens
l'effort pour la rencontre parce qu'on
est fait c'est pas toujours facile la
solidarité mais qu'est ce qu'on est
récompensé alors donc on est une petite
association de chambéry très dynamique
enthousiaste volontaire et donc on se
dit ben
on va on va faire des actions surtout en
france pour gagner d avoir des faux et
puis la rébellion touareg s'installent
là bas et je comprends que on pourra pas
y retourner tout de suite donc pour
l'instant on fait rentrer des sous dans
l'association et ça tombe bien parce que
en 2009 graves inondations à agadez
soixante dix mille sinistrés est donc là
on propose de financer une aide et qu'on
appelait ça des nets de survie donc on a
fait des kits de survie grâce à mohamed
qui nous avait fait traverser le ténéré
cinq ans avant et qu'ils étaient donc
sur place à agadez grâce à une accalmie
un peu politique entre la rébellion et
l'aqmi les trois filles on a réussi à y
retourner on a eu notre visa et on a pu
aller sur place
m un partenaire un partenariat avec
notre frère mohamed qui a toute notre
confiance et aussi mettre en place des
micro crédits
alors on les micro-crédits c'est pour
des femmes en difficultés qui sont
vraiment très démunis elles sont soit
veut soit divorce et des enfants
handicapés et donc on va leur prêter 30
ou 40 euros si elles qui choisissent la
somme si elles qui choisissent en
combien de temps ils peuvent nous
rembourser donc elle avait choisi six
mois et elles peuvent acheter comme ça
la matière première
faire leur petit artisanat et ensuite le
vendre et pouvoir ensuite nous
rembourser et puis quand vingt femmes
ont fini de payer leurs micros crédits
il y en a vingt 20 autres qui qui
peuvent en bénéficier
à la fin de la réunion je leur dise
par contre je vous prête 30 euros mais
bon il faut payer des frais de dossier
de 1 euro 50 et là plus personne ne
rigole je regarde un match dit mais j'ai
dit quoi j'ai dit un gros mot il dit a
pas dit gros mots tu leur as demande un
euro cinquante h 10 alors elles n'ont
pas a donc là je me suis dit oh là là tu
avais pas encore tout compris soit là
sur la pauvreté la misère mais pas de
problème je vous prête 30 euros vous me
rendez un euro cinquante et tout va bien
et le les rires ont repris et tout
allait bien quand on est rentré de 2,7
ce passage à agadez l'a vraiment les
mouvements
il se la miss l'extrémiste ont vraiment
été se sont aggravées et là j'ai
vraiment compris qu'on n'était pas prêts
d'y retourner
alors je me suis dit qu'est ce qu'on va
faire
mohamed pour aider ses amis nos amis
touareg sans pouvoir y aller
pas de problème clair tu va construire
une école ah bon où ça un marc d'haene
dans l'aïr mais pourquoi parce que le
village il n'a qu'une école paillote est
donc vraiment ça fait dix ans qu'ils
demandent à l'état de la construire en
dur et puis aussi m'expliquer que pour
qu'un enfant nomades aillent à l'école
il faut qu ils y dorment et qu'il y
mange
faut-il donc parce que les parents sont
des semi nomades et qui peuvent avoir
leur campement à 10 ou 15 km alors moi
qui toujours pensé depuis très longtemps
je voulais faire quelque chose contre la
faim dans le monde je me suis dit quel
beau cadeau là je vais pouvoir nourrir
des enfants en vrai alors donc on
n'avait donc pas mal travaillé pendant
toutes ces années donc on peut se lancer
et on va commencer par faire le puits le
réservoir le jardin scolaire deux salles
de classe en dur et installer la cantine
et puis aussi on a fait deux latrines ça
c'était en 2011 les instituteurs étaient
payés par l'état
quand ils le font parce que ça c'est un
autre problème en 2012 on a pu faire
deux dortoirs
grâce à la fondation orange qui nous les
a beaucoup aidés
l'état s'est un peu réveillé il a fait
deux salles de classe et puis un jour
moi même midi au téléphone toujours
clair tu sais il fait froid l'hiver il
faudrait quand même qu'ils aient des
couvertures pour les internes quoi tient
bon la maman elle peut bien donner une
couverture quand même et il me répond la
couverture oulala autre leçon d'humilité
jci a pas ce qu'il y'a qu'une couverture
pour toute la famille dorment tous sous
la même couverture pas de problème moi
mais je vais trouver l'argent on va
acheter 60 couvertures pour les internes
et là elle bonheur de voir ses enfants
recevoir leur plus beau cadeau une
couverture personnel
donc en 2013
j'ai eu l'idée comme ça et si on mettait
des panneaux solaires sur sur l'école
comme ça les enfants sort il pourrait
faire leurs devoirs
jeudi en même temps pourrait en mettre
sur le centre de santé du village et moi
elle me dit mais quel centre de santé
une manne d'iberia alors mon mari qui
passait par là et qui a entendu la
conversation m'a dit ah non plaire tu
vas pas faire ça et c'est vrai que j
avais pas tout de suite pensé mais du
coup j'ai dit eh ben si on va faire un
centre de santé
alors là par contre on avait pas le
moindre premier sou alors on a il a
fallu attendre un petit peu
j'ai passé un concours dermato du coeur
que j'ai gagné de la roche posay et puis
la fondation orange nous a aidés encore
une deuxième fois ils nous ont fait
confiance et on a pu comme ça financer
le centre de santé et son équipement
alors maintenant que le village il à son
école sa cantine son internat qui a un
centre de santé
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
améliorer l'éducation et la santé
et bien déjà pour améliorer l'éducation
il faut bien manger
aujourd'hui on est très fier car nos 100
enfants mangent trois repas par jour il
ya 42 % de filles donc on est très très
fiers et donc il manque trois repas par
jour avec des légumes et des céréales
on est en train de faire de planter un
verger pour qu'ils aient un jour des
fruits
sinon on a mis un panneau solaire sur
une des fameuses classes donc ils
peuvent faire leurs devoirs le soir et
on a aussi mis en place une bourse au
mérite pour trois quatre enfants de cm2
qui sont motivés que les parents sont
d'accord qui partent à la ville pour
aller au collège
tagada et cela depuis 2015 2016 pour
améliorer la santé
c'est d'abord l'eau courante aman iman
l'eau c'est la vie
et là vraiment pour moi c'était très
important quand on faisait nos trek
médicaux il y avait toujours des
robinets dans les centres de santé
on disait toujours qu'il fallait se
laver les mains n'y avait jamais d'eau
dans le nôtre il y aura l'eau courante
alors là il a fallu attendre du temps
trois années pour avoir les fonds pour
construire un château d'eau avoir une
pompe solaire et grâce à chambéry
métropole depuis 2007 il y à l'eau
courante alors ça pour vous ça vous
paraît complètement anodin on ouvre un
robinet ya de l'eau mais moi je n'ai
jamais oublié et à chaque fois que vous
me robin et j'y pense
pour améliorer la santé va on a aussi
mis un panneau solaire ramène sur le
centre de santé comme ça l'infirmière
elle peut faire les soins le soir il est
des accouchements de nuit sans avoir la
lampe à pétrole qui tombe sur la vente
de la maman est également très important
ah oui le réfrigérateur solaire donc
maintenant on peut faire des campagnes
de vaccination est très important
l'ambulance alors ça c'était attendu
depuis très très longtemps
et parce que là bas qu'est ce qui se
passe si vous êtes malade le premier
hôpital
il est à deux jours de chameau et sinon
donc une appendicite c'est le cimetière
est donc là les villageois attendent ça
depuis longtemps si à peu près pour dix
mille personnes marc d'année les
alentours et donc
l'ambulance est arrivée cet été elle est
fonctionnelle et elle sauve des vies
tous les jours alors toutes ses
réalisations
c'est du travail c'est du temps passé
des doutes c'est aussi parfois de
l'épuisement
mais alors quel bonheur de voir ses
enfants heureux de vivre ensemble
d'apprendre ensemble de manger ensemble
de jouer ensemble filles et garçons au
foot en plein milieu du désert
quel bonheur pour nous de voir ces beaux
légumes du jardin
quel bonheur de pouvoir permettre à
quelques-uns d'avoir un métier un jour
quel bonheur de voir ces femmes démunies
reprendre un peu d'autonomie avec leurs
petites activités artisanales et quel
bonheur de voir ces villageois se
prendre en charge pour améliorer leur
avenir
mais coup de tonnerre dans un ciel
serein le 13 août graves inondations au
niger 70 mille sinistrés
et à marc d'haene 209 familles
sinistrées les jardins sont tous
dévastés donc l'ida plus de légumes il
n'y a plus rien à manger pendant trois
mois avant les prochaines récoltes
donc là non seulement on peut mourir de
soif dans le désert on peut mourir de
faim et on peut aussi s'y noyer
donc quand est-ce que ça va s'arrêter et
n'a jamais donc on repart sur le chemin
d'assaut la vérité on retrousse ses
manches
on cherche l'énergie et on sait que ça
fait du bien d'être solidaires alors on
retrouve cette énergie là et donc appel
aux dons d'urgence pour ensuite faire
des kits de survie
alors aujourd'hui sur les 209 famille en
à 98 qui sont vraiment nécessiteuses et
qui sont celles qui sont courageuses qui
veulent refaire leur jardin pour
l'instant on a pu en et des 60 alors la
solidarité c'est une vraie aventure
humaine parfois difficile mais surtout
riche en rencontres qui nous permettent
d'avancer à fulda fousse main dans la
main pour une même cause et qui rendent
heureux moi j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer mohamed sans lui rien
n'aurait pu se faire
il me rassure il m'encourage
il me donne sa force pour continuer
encore et encore envers et contre tout
en gardant l'espérance est vraiment quel
bonheur quand moi mais ne dit au
téléphone
pas de problème ma soeur tout va
s'arranger
alors que c'est eux qui sont vraiment
dans la panade c'est lui qui me remonte
le moral est bon
j'ai aussi compris pourquoi je n'avais
jamais eu peur pendant toute cette
aventure qui a duré 14 ans c'est parce
que mohammed était là sans rien dire et
je l' ai compris
quelques années après quand mohamed est
venue en france et qu'il est interviewé
à radio france bleue où il a dit mais
moi chez nous quand un touareg accueil
il meurt à sa place et là j'ai tout est
revenu j'ai compris pourquoi je n'avais
je m'étais toujours senti en sécurité
avec lui j'ai aussi beaucoup de chance
de rencontrer mano qui m'a fait
l'immense joie de guérir et quelques
années plus tard d'aller s'inscrire
une école pour apprendre à lire et à
écrire pour un jour écrire à une blanche
qui de passage l'avait soigné d'une
graves brûlures
la boucle est bouclée pour moi j'ai
soigné mano s'inscrit à l'école nous
avons construit une école et nous avons
construit un centre de santé
j'ai aussi la chance de rencontrer tous
ceux qui m'aident sur ce chemin de la
solidarité en apportant leur petit grain
de sable pour aider les villageois de
marc d'haene a retrouvé le sourire et
l'espoir de mieux vivre chez eux alors
être solidaire je me dis que c'est
peut-être aussi être un petit peu
égoïste puisque ça apporte du bonheur
alors n'ayez pas peur soyez solidaires
votre bonheur commence peut-être par là
je vous souhaite à tous de très belles
rencontres
merci
[Applaudissements]